هل اتنحب الى المستقبل
يلتزم بمبدا حريه التعبير
الموقع يطلق الكثير من استطلاعات الراي
على كل شيء من استعاده حساب ترامب الى
المنصه او تقديم عفو عام للحسابات المعلقه
واخرها استطلاع ما اذا كان يجب ان يستمر
في منصبه شارك اكثر من 17 مليون مستخدم
عبر تويتر في الاستطلاع الاخير واجابه نصف
المستخدمين او حوالي 57
نعم قال لانه سيلتزم بنتائج هذا الاستطلاع
لكنه الان يغرد بشكل طبيعي على حسابه وكان
شيئا لم يكن المزيد في هذا التقرير عشان
يريد سليمان لك
بس تطلعي راي بريء العالم قال كلمته
بصراحه وعلى الملا اللي لهم ماسك الذي
اثار باستراتيجيته المعتاده الجدله مجددا
عندما سال المستخدمين هل تريدونني ان
اتنازل عن منصبي سؤال بريء اليس كذلك حسنا
ليس تماما عندما يطرح لهم ماسك هكذا
استفتاء فهو يعرف نتيجه مسبقا واتخذ قراره
قبل طرحه
ثم العين
تويتر تنازل عن منصبك في استفتاء رسم
نهايه رئاسه ماسك التنفيذيه للمنصه
الشهيره بعد استحوذه عليها قبل شهرين فقط
لفتره وصفت بعرض السيرك بدات بهذه
التغريده الهزليه وتفعل على اثرها 44
مليار دولار للاستحواذ على المنصه
ولكن هذا ليس الاستفتاء الوحيد الذي اجراه
ماسك على تويتر فمن منا لا يتذكر استطلاع
راي اعاده حساب ترامب على المنصه او اخر
استطلاعن حول اعاده حسابات الصحفيين الذين
اثروا غضب رائد الاعمال الشهير الذي اجرى
جمله من التغييرات من تسريح نحو نصف
العاملين وفضل رسوم مقابل وضع علامه
التحقق الزرقاء قبل ان تتوقف المحاوله
ليعود الامر الى سابق عهده قبل اسبوع
[تصفيق]
العالم الان بانتظار الاعلان عن الرئيس
التنفيذي الجديد لتويتر بعد اشهر قليله
ولكنه وصفت بالصعبه لماسك وتويتر
ولمستخدميه تويتر وبانتظار الاعلان عن
سياسه واستراتيجيات جديده قد لا تكونوا
بالضروره مثيره للجدل كما اعتدنا مؤخرا
لصباح العربيه ريتا سليمان واشنطن
من عمان
التزم بتناحي تناحي الى الماسك وماذا بعد
بعد
انا اعتقد انه نعم هو ملتزم بالتنحيف صباح
الخير اول شيء صباح النور
لم تكن هذه الخطوه لتكون لولا ان مزازه
مدير التنفيذي الذي سوف يقول هذه المنصه
وكامل
بمنتصف الامس
تويتر
للبدء بالعمل
وما يجري الان هي عمليه خروج مشرف يحفظ
ماء الوجه للسيد لهم ماسك همم من خلال
خروج من اداره نعم هل بدي افهم منك انا
كلمه هل ماسك اراد رئاسه تويتر
واليوم اقتنع بفكره انه اعطي الخبز لخبازه
خليني ارجع على صناعه السيارات الكهربائيه
والوصول الى الفضاء
انا اعتقد ان انتم جاوبتها السؤال الى
خلال تقرير كما قالوا انه علاقه حب يعني
له الماسك يعني على علاقه حب مع هذه
المنصه ولكن حب نرجسيه حب سادي من طرف
واحد وليس من طرفين بدليل على انه يعني
اكثر من 57% من المستطاع اراه قالوا له
ارحل تتعمل عمليا وجوده حضوره
لانه هو مدير لشركه تسلا شركه سيارات وفي
من المعلمين كثير من شركات السيارات
احجموا عن المشاركه واوقف وحملها يعني
بالتالي كان لابد من عمليه قيصريه همم
حتى
تعود حركه الاعلانات مره اخرى وبالتالي او
تعود حركته اعلانات وتعود حركه تويتر كما
يحبها المستخدمين طيب السؤال انه لفتني
بعض التعليقات على استطلاع راي لاجره الى
النص احدهم قال السؤال ليس العثور على غني
يشتري تويتر هذه العصفور الازرق ولكن
العثور على مدير تنفيذي يبقي هذا الطائر
الازرق على قيد الحياه ما رايكم بذلك هل
من خليفه مرشح
لحد الان لكن انا اقول دائما شركات
لا يمكن ان تطرح مثل هذه المساله دون ان
تكون مستعد لاستعداد كامل الامور منتهي
على مستوى من هو المدير
يبدانا فقدنا الاتصال مع استاذ رائد سمور
على كل حال كان حديثا شيقا معه لمرحله ما
بعد الى ماسك لرئاسه تويتر خبير عن
المعلومات